how's it going everyone this is
International master Daniel wrench this
is chess comm and this is the everything
you need to know video series here today
to bring you the third installment on
the endgame on that note if you haven't
watched the first two videos in this
series everything you need to know about
the opening as well as tactics and
strategy now is the time to do so as our
promise to you that this can be the one
chess lesson in your life if you are
only to get one would not be fulfilled
if you have not watched the first two in
this series the endgame is the final
stage of a chess game and it is
generally considered to be reached when
most of the material has been traded in
particular the Queen's however that can
not obviously be true for every endgame
as certainly there exist queen endings
perhaps with just the king and the queen
and a few pawns so in designing this
video and outlining it for you we
decided to organize it around the two
most critical factors that define an
endgame these would be the factors that
define how well you play the endgame and
that is king activity and the ability to
create a passed pawn or in some cases
the simple execution of an already
existing passport so as we jump right in
here most of the technical positions and
the practical ideas we're going to teach
you are designed around executing and
getting the most out of the King
activity and your pawn play as you
transition into the final stage we hope
you're ready hope you got your popcorn
and you're ready to rock and roll
because we certainly are let's jump into
talking about the active King first
thing we'd like to point out is
something that many players overlook and
that is that your King is an important
piece though it wouldn't be smart to
bring the King out in the middle game
obviously as he's also your most
valuable piece in the one piece you
can't lose you should be aware that your
King is a powerful piece and is actually
the only other piece outside of the
Queen that attacks or controls every
Square directly surrounding it
the only other piece outside of the
Queen that does that in some cases the
King even has the ability to target and
trap minor pieces by himself as we see
in
this case a king has trapped the enemy
Knight in the corner and here we see
that your King even has the ability to
execute a double attack tactic or fork
tactic as we saw and everything you need
to know about tactics and strategy video
here black will either lose the
undefended knight or move the knight to
safety thus falling will be the bishop
on f4 you will see throughout this video
that the active King and the position of
either an active or passive King can be
the determining factor of either a win
loss or draw an endgame one example of
the King position determining the result
of an endgame would be this one here as
neither side can really make progress
given that both Kings are relatively
active though White's King is slightly
more active because black can simply
hold opposition by staying in front the
white King will not have the ability and
will never find the ability to make
progress however if we change the
position of the Kings even slightly we
see that White has the ability to win
this endgame due to the fact that his
King will reach the King side pawns much
faster note that there are really no
other differences in this pawn structure
or in this position outside of the
position of the Kings but white is
easily winning after quickly entering we
will see that black's timing is just far
enough behind as white will get to the
Kings side and much enough pawns to
eventually promote and win the endgame
King and pawn endings are not the only
positions where either the active or
passive position of the King can be the
deciding factor here we see a position
where white would like to promote his
past pawn on h7 however the rook on h8
must stay there to defend the pawn and
any passive movement of the rook will
simply allow capture the 911 - might
also like to join the party and help
White Queen to pass pawn however at the
current time the knight has no way to
enter play Andrey maneuvering and
redeployment of the piece may not help
in this position white found the
important move in fact the only winning
idea and that involved the activity of
the white King on b3 what should be
noted is the two of the criteria we
listed at the beginning of this video as
what defines an endgame are present in
this position a passed pawn and then
to activate the king white played the
move a for this was a strong move as at
the current time black is unable to give
check to the black King which would
otherwise force it black due to the fact
that white can capture the rook after
black captures on a four we see quickly
that the white King now has the ability
to enter into the game where it
otherwise previously did not because of
the Brooks restriction of the
fourth-ranked after a four takes and
takes we see that the black King is
unable to challenge the act of white
king due to the fact that if it leaves
the seventh rank Y will move this rook
with check followed by immediate
promotion in this case blacks King has
become a completely passive piece as it
must hold the seventh rank in order to
prevent progress whereas the white King
now has easy access into the game this
game was soon won by white after the
moves rook h2 King to b5 rook h4 King to
c5 rook h2 came to d6 and again we
should have been able to see the black
is unable to capture the night of - due
to the fact that immediately leaving the
h5 would result in a loss after one of
two ways simply moving the rook followed
by promotion allowing black to give up
the rook for the Queen and easily
winning the endgame as the Brooke is a
much better piece than the bishop or
simply sacrificing the rook with check
in order to force promotion through on
the next move in this position after
King to d6 black simply resigned
realizing that there was no way to take
the knight end of - nor was there any
way to activate his own King for fear of
check on the eighth-ranked as we
highlighted nor was there any way to
prevent the plan of the white king
reaching the g7 square protecting the h7
pawn and eventually releasing the rook
from his duties so that this pawn may
promote to a queen to highlight this in
an example these might be the moves to
end the game if black decided not to
capture the knight up that I don't have
- eventually white would find promotion
for this pawn immediately and in the
game hopefully this example highlights
clearly that one major advantage of an
endgame is always a passed pawn as the
ability to promote a pawn into a high
rated peace particularly the queen is
always a dangerous threat secondly it
should highlight for you that the King
activity was eventually the deciding
factor as without the active King White
was unable to execute the advantage of a
passed pawn we see the need to use both
an active King and to have a goal which
is to eventually promote your passed
pawns a very common goal in most end
games as the deciding factors in this
practical endgame almost all King and
pawn endings where one side possesses an
extra pawn should be winning though we
do not have time to review all of the
technique required in these positions
nor do we have time to discuss all the
practical ideas the one position that
all players should know is this one in
front of you White has King on the sixth
pawn on the fifth when that structure is
reached with the King leading the way
the position is always a force when
outside of possessing a rook pawn a
corner pawn in this position if it is
black to move either one of these moves
is met by King infiltration with King to
d8 being met by King to f7 and King to
f8 being met by King to d7 followed by
the pawn marching to victory and even on
White's turn the King can simply
sidestep and March the pawn forward
eventually placing black in a position
where he must move and allow us to come
forward followed by promotion of the
pawn as we move on to slightly more
complicated positions to discuss the
nature of pawn playing the endgame
remember this position as one of your
goals as something you can always strive
to achieve an end games as the King on
the six pawn in the fifth position wins
regardless of whose move it is outside
of possessing a large material advantage
in the endgame or perhaps even a small
material advantage as we saw in the last
example one of the biggest advantages
one can have is that of a protected pass
pawn in this position though both sides
possess two pawns white structure is
easily winning the pawn on b5 is a solid
rock black does not have the ability to
ever rid himself of this thorn in his
sight why because the only way to ever
take the b5 pawn would be to rid himself
of the a4 pawn but black does not have
the ability to ever go chasing this pawn
as doing so would leave the b5 pawn to
rush toward a queen to simply highlight
this point we can shuffle the white King
back and
without even trying to show aggressive
intentions towards blacks extra pawn
because we see that if black ever leaves
the B file this white pawn pushes and
black does not have the ability to catch
up with it in this case the black King
is completely stuck never being able to
run too far to protect the rest of his
army as this pawn would Queen nor can he
ever eliminate the pawn as doing so
would also allow the pawn to Queen and
this position white can simply come back
toward the King side eliminate the h7
pawn eventually make his way back over
to the Queen side and win the game
another large advantage one can possess
in the end game outside of material or
that of a protective passed pawn as in
the last example is an outside pass pawn
here we see once again the material
being equal with both sides possessing
three pawns
however White's pawn being a passed pawn
that is far away from the rest of the
army makes a huge difference and it is a
significant advantage why you can easily
advance this pawn using it as a decoy to
force the black King away and in doing
so the white King can infiltrate and be
miles ahead of the black King in terms
of the bigger prize we see that an
outside pass pawn when recognized as an
advantage can be a huge problem for the
opponent as getting rid of so requires a
long journey for the King and always
leaves the rest of the enemy exposed
recognizing the possibility to execute
an outside pass pawn advantage allowed
white to play a famous combination in
this game after capturing on f6 white
first threatens to follow it up with a
fork and therefore head toward an
endgame with an extra minor piece
however black did not have to capture
back and simply took on c3 in this
position white continued the combination
by capturing the f7 pawn before
recapturing the rook on c3 and in this
end game despite blacks slightly more
active King white is easily winning
that's because the potential to create
an outside pass pawn exists with a
two-on-one majority advantage after
advancing black eventually found himself
in a position where he had no other
choice
to allow white to create an outside pass
pawn white does so willingly just so
that he can sacrifice it as he has the
knowledge that what really matters is
who's King is closer to the other side
of the board again we see the outside
pass pawn being much better than the
central pass pawn as it forces the king
further away black can take the pawn
immediately allowing white to capture
followed by an easy win or black and try
to hold on a little bit longer by
waiting though eventually he will be
forced to deal with this outside pass
pawn monster and in doing so the black
king will be too far to deal with
White's threat recognizing the potential
for a two-on-one majority in that last
position allowed white to execute a
brilliant combination a majority exists
when you have more pawns than the
opponent on one side of the board and
that idea has dictated the play even in
some very famous opening repertoires for
example the Rui Lopez or Spanish game
shown even in our first video has one
variation known as the exchange where
white soul ideas to exchange the bishop
for Knight and eventually trade the
pawns in the center without going any
further to show the theory of this
position the main idea to highlight is
that White's goal is a long-term one
white now has a four-on-three
King side Paul majority and if best play
followed from White's perspective the
pieces would be traded eventually
heading toward a position where black
was lost in the endgame because his
four-on-three pawn majority is not as
effective due to the double pawns on the
C file as we learned in the tactics of
strategy video double pawns are
disadvantaged due to the fact that they
cannot protect each other and that they
stunt progress and in an endgame such as
this where White's four-on-three
majority could dictate play this could
be a deciding factor
one final practical example is designed
to show the potential of a passed pawn
once again here we see that black has an
advantage due to the outside pass before
pawn however white has established a
blockade on the Queen side in this
position black one easily recognizing
that his majority on the King side was
real due to white's doubled pawns
leaving black with a two-on-one
outside chance black played the move h5
and went on to win very quickly as this
was a very strong move followed by g5
and h4 note White's
inability to deal with this plan the
main point being recognizing an open
file for a pawn is like recognizing a
pretender as it's been known to be
called a pretender is a pawn that no
longer has an enemy pawn on the same
file and all it needs is to help from
his majority in order to become pass
combining these ideas of the last few
examples should help you to recognize
the potential for past pawns and your
own end games and the practical ideas of
how to execute them in review two
factors dictate the play of all roughly
equal end games and they are king play
and power and pass pawns as nimzowitsch
said in the middle game the King has put
a mere extra but in the endgame the king
is a principal activate your King at the
earliest opportunity use him to help
your pawns advance and remember the goal
position of King on the sixth pot on the
fifth as it is a goal position for many
end games pawns are the soul of chess
according to Philidor and if you
recognize the potential for your
majorities you can create passed pawns
all over the board remember the ideas of
protected passed pawns outside pass
pawns and push push push your passports
to victory everything you need to know
about the endgame is now complete we
hope you enjoyed this video and we will
see you around on chess calm